what are the things that make for a good
or bad date the date doesn't just start
when you show up the date actually
starts hours before when you get into
the mindset so my version of an old
quote is whether you think the date will
go poorly or you think the date will go
well you're right your mindset matters
so if you're transitioning from a hard
day at work where your boss was yelling
at you and going straight into a date
you're not going to bring an excitable
Present part of yourself you're going to
bring a stressed part so I want you to
proactively take time between work or
whatever else you're doing and the date
and getting into a mindset so many dates
or these job interviews where I sit
across from you and I say what did you
study and why and how many siblings do
you have and what's your Five-Year Plan
and you know what who cares that doesn't
really affect our ability to be in a
relationship together it's dry it's
boring why can't we have an experience
together where we're doing something
we're having fun even if we don't have a
connection at least we had a fun
experience together and it takes the
pressure off so designing a date with a
lot of fun and playfulness